he is the great conservative hope the
hardliner
Ibrahim er easy tens of thousands of
people gather in the mosque in Tehran to
hear him speak it's the home stretch of
the presidential campaign and as he
takes to the stage the crowd goes wild
ricey is the only candidate who could
spell trouble for president Hassan
rouhani he's on the offensive attacking
the record of rouhani especially on the
economy he's tried to bring in a key
from outside to unlock the sanctions and
solve the economic problems of the
country but the key for all problems is
in the hand of the Iranian people race
is the candidate of the ultra
conservatives in Iran he has the backing
of the powerful security forces and of
many religious voters you know yet said
he's honest he's pure and he knows how
things are done he's better than all the
others - all right I see mister I see is
more local and representative for the
Iranian people president rouhani is to
Western about my rouhani I know honey
you're gonna target on me we cannot it's
not possible that is all he ever says
but he doesn't know how we feel I want a
president who says it is possible we can
do it
Misha had away from the rally on the
streets of Tehran the mood is not so
clear-cut according to the latest polls
Ibrahim raizy and president rouhani are
both neck to neck
neither of them falling above the
decisive 50 percent mark many people are
still undecided over which candidate to
choose and whether to even vote at all
there despite the election being so
crucial in deciding the future of Iran
the reformists in particular are doing
all they can to get their supporters to
the polls low voter turnout could be
especially parallels for president
rouhani according to political analysts
sure I got Nagoya queen V Ross are you
Jim hood it usually incumbent presidents
are elected for a second term in Iran
but if no Hani's voters just assume that
this will happen again and do not go to
vote then the other side will win giant
stock dilemma home yahwah honey
one thing is certain right easy
supporters will go to the polls
they're determined to see their rallying
cry country at the weekend they change
your Hani will be gone
[Applause]